there's a chapter in my book where I
talk about how every man at some point
should own a motorcycle in his life you
just bought a BMW
r1000r I was actually looking at that
bike earlier this year I was thinking oh
man I miss bikes I want to get another
one I'm also looking at vrod night rods
I don't [__] know where I'm gonna get
what where I'm gonna store it I just
miss bikes for sure man I get it does
that resonate with you do you think a
man should own a motorcycle at some
point in his life yes or no and you know
explain why yeah I think I think if you
can sit on the toilet and think because
most men do think on the toilet so let's
in the toilet and they'll think imagine
that same experience but doing it on a
motorcycle where nobody can say anything
to you and just Vis early your body I
that's even the proper word to say but
your body does something that you can't
control when you have that acceleration
pulling you back all the time and you
are in full control yes 100% And that
that that dose of danger it just it's a
whole different game you feel in control
there's nothing that you can also the
other part of it is cost right to get
into the cost of motorcycles a lot
cheaper now this BMW is fairly expensive
from from a bike perspective but you can
get any cheap bike to get in the problem
is that you still have to have maturity
before you get behind the wheel so even
though you're you're behind the bike and
every man should have a bike for sure
there's still seem to be some level of
maturity because you're your life and
death is right here and that's really
how you should run your life right you
should run your life almost a life and
death you should always be in like a
mature controlled environment in your
mind like your whole Space has to be
mature but you have to take risks and
you have to do it from a cost effective
standpoint and as motorcycles do they
put you in a cost effective space where
you can get that you know the adrenaline
the acceleration the the cost of fuel
maybe insurance is a little bit of a
different Factor but it'll give you and
also makes you somewhat cool I mean you
have all those pieces by getting a
motorcycle it'll automatically give you
that coolness you don't have to go shop
for the perfect shirt you can just get
on a motorcycle you'll automatically
feel cooler it's the dumbest thing but
it's not how how we feel I've always
personally felt you know yeah I agree
and the other thing about motorcycles
man is it puts you in a community that's
smaller with Risk Takers it's it's crazy
to say people that are generally on
motorcycles now I will say obviously if
you get on on a on more of a comfort a
luxury a Harley it's still a community
for sure maybe a little bit less
risk-taking but nothing feels like open
air life it's like the convertible Vibe
right it's a conver it makes you feel
like makes you feel committed to it so
so the so I'll quickly just end this
with with this is that when I knew my
son was being born I said I'm done I'm
not driving motorcycle it's too
dangerous I'm worth too much money I'm
too valuable to lose off this planet and
I do not want to hurt this body
now my son is 12 he's an adult I've
coached him the best way I could as a
man but also understanding how to be
humble how to care but always be driven
but for me right now I feel like man I'm
at this pace in my in my life where I
still want that adrenaline I do have
fast cars I do have great other
experiences around me but I feel like a
motorcycle just is like one little tick
on my mind where I feel like I was
always into bikes and now I'm bringing
it back so call it what you want midlife
crisis call it like hey he's got the
freedom to do it but when I felt like
when I was married I just felt like I
just didn't need to do it but now I'm
I'm I'm super grateful that my ex left
me I'm like yes she left me I'm free to
do what I want I still had freedom but
now it's like my own controlled Freedom
right it's like that comforting food
that I'm by myself and I'm My Own man
and I feel like man there's nothing more
the world man you only know when you
know when you you know when you put your
leg over that machine and strap on the
helmet you twist throttle with your
right hand you know those that know no
that don't they just think it's it's too
dangerous and it's a wrong
recommendation I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clip's from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out